what world do you find most mysterious
or beautiful the very big or the very
small
the very small seems a lot more
mysterious and i mean they're very big i
feel like we kind of understand i mean
not the very very big not the not the
multiverse if there is a multiverse uh
not anything outside of the observable
universe
um but the very small we i think we
really have no idea what's going on um
or very you know much less idea but i
find that so i think the smaller more
mysterious but i think the big is
sexier um
i
just cannot
get enough of the bigness of space and
the farness of stars
and it just continually blows my mind i
mean we still the vastness
of the observable universe has the
mystery that we don't know what's out
there we know how it works perhaps like
general relativity can tell us how the
the movement of bodies works how they're
born all that kind of things
but like how many lit how many
civilizations are out there how many
like what are the weird things that are
also yeah life well extraterrestrial
life is a true mystery the most
tantalizing mystery of all um
uh but that that's like our size so
that's maybe it's that the the actual uh
the big and the small are really cool
but it's actually the things that are
potentially our size that are the most
tantalizing potentially our size is
probably the key word yeah i mean i
wonder how small intelligent life could
get probably not that small um and i
assume that there's a limit that you're
not gonna you might have like a whale
blue whale-sized intelligent being that
would be kind of cool um but i i um i
feel like it's we're in the range of
order of magnitude smaller and bigger
than us for life but maybe maybe not
maybe you could have some giant life
form just seems like
i don't know there's a there's got to be
some reason that anything intelligence
between kind of like a little tiny
rodent or finger monkey
up to a blue whale on this planet
i don't know maybe maybe when you change
the gravity you know gravity and other
things
well you could think of life as a thing
of self-assembling
organisms and they just get bigger and
bigger and bigger like there's no such
thing as a human being a human being is
made up of a bunch of tiny organisms
working together and we somehow envision
that as one
entity because it has consciousness but
maybe it's just organisms on top of
organisms
organisms all the way down turtles all
the way down so like earth can be seen
as an organism for people for um
alien species that's very different
like why is the human the fundamental
entity that is living
and then every everything else is just
either a collection of humans or
components of humans i think if it kind
of is if you think about i think of like
an emergence elevator and so you've got
an ant is on one's floor and then the
ant colonies you know a floor above
or maybe there's even units within the
colony that's one floor above and the
full colonies of two floors above and to
me i think that it's the colony that is
the closest to being the animal uh it's
like the the individual thing where that
competes
with others um while the
the individual ants are like cells in
the animal's body
we are more like a colony in that regard
but the the humans are weird because we
kind of we i think of it if emergence
happens in an emergence tower um when
you've got kind of you know as i said
cells and then humans and
communities and societies ants are very
specific you know the individual ants
are always cooperating with each other
uh for the sake of the colony so the
colony is this unit that is that is the
competitive unit
humans can kind of go we take the
elevator up and down emergence tower
psychologically sometimes we are
individuals that are
uh competing with other individuals and
that that's where our mindset is and
then other times we get in this crazy
zone you know a protest or a sporting
event and you're just you know you're
just chanting and screaming and doing
the same hand motions with all these
other people and you feel like one you
feel like one you know and you sacrifice
yourself you know that's what you know
soldiers and so our brains can kind of
psychologically go up and down this
elevator in an interesting way
you